thanks to nvidia and puget for
sponsoring this video stick around to
learn how you can get a geforce rtx 3090
powered system from puget systems
[Music]
so huge it just hooked me up with a
beautiful new computer it has a geforce
rtx 3090 in it which is an insanely fast
graphics card and i want to benchmark
this computer i want to see just how
fast it is so what i want to do is i
want to open up an
old corridor project one of the ones
that i grew up watching i want to open
up that dusty after effects file
and i want to remaster and re-render
this file to see
just how fast and beautiful this
graphics card really is
you nailed it man hell yeah wait i need
your help opening the archives i don't
know how to do it
if legend has it correctly and legend
does have it
there are some archives deep within the
corridor studio that contain the old
project files
supposedly they haven't been touched in
eons
i need your help opening these come back
let's dust off some drives baby so the
real question is
do we still have the footage why do you
believe
we don't have the footage people here
historically have had a habit of just
deleting old stuff on the server because
we run out of room
there's only one way to know for sure to
open the archives
i actually forgot we've it's probably
been offloaded to
one of those old hard drives they're
cataloged through a spreadsheet
that carmichael made five years ago hey
by the way
i single-handedly packaged and labeled
each one of these so if we can't find it
it could be my fault party bucket
remember the party bucket yeah it had
all our vfx elements in there
it's just a whole bunch of pirated 2010
programs
hey guys we have to break into the
business somehow
[Music]
oh my god dude i just about
passed out oh we got it
we found it so there is a very real
chance
that even though we found the correct
hard drive the hard drive might just be
dead you guys ready i'm gonna plug in
the drive's not showing up
that's it
i think you hit the power button when
you put that back down oh did i you
didn't
oh no what is this
i was just plugging in the hard drive i
was assuming it was already plugged in
after that
all right ready close the moment of
truth
it's fire enough
it's alive glitches who knows oh i'm
opening the premiere file
for the glitch see let's see what
happens
whoa wait what this is the footage i
love when premium does that
whoa dude this is like i think the red
files are so old they're from here can't
read them
i don't know man and we ended up not
being able to find any project files
right here oh that's the sun i want to
have sun
we did find the footage though which
means that we can actually do the effect
but
i have no idea how they did it
originally and i want to pay respect
to the originals like we did with the
tron video you know you gotta copy the
process
i'm not actually sure who did this shot
because i was
i think i was born when this came out i
was probably like three or four
years old i'm gonna have to dig into
this archaeologically to figure out who
did this shot and what they did
because if i can learn how the original
artists did this shot that can inform
the way i do it so i can
get it close to the original yet with
today's technology and advancements
so sam i have some questions for you
okay
you know i want to recreate this glitch
shot do you know who the original artist
was
the original artist was me
like december 2011 do you think there's
any way you could
rewind your brain kind of tap into those
deep memories and remember how you did
this effect
guys this is like eight years ago i've
done so many vfx shots
how am i supposed to figure this out
look at me
should i like close my eyes take three
deep breaths
now close your eyes and think about it
was 2011.
what do you hear on hunter street do you
hear construction or like a lot of cpu
fans
hundreds of cpu fans i want to take you
to a time
when your life was much better no
worries on your mind but how am i going
to do this excellent vfx shot today
i got the footage in the timeline try
and think
tracking manual track pf track
pf skyrim
i'm really i'm actually there now guys
i'm there in 2011 i'm playing skyrim and
it's awesome
get skyrim out of your head no no no no
no no no no character customization
face face face space jam face jam face
check
face jan face chin keep going i've lost
i've
i'm playing skyrim again this is uh this
is not working
we gotta try something else we need to
find another way to access this memories
it's
like a smell sam what snacks were you
eating circa 2012
from 2011 to like 2016 on the
eve of every video release when we
crunched and got it done
i'd always drink a giant xxx vitamin
water with a five-hour energy shot in it
hey right there
right there there it is
so if everything goes according to plan
this concoction
should bring sam's brain back in time
all of it okay
bring it to me
i can tell you everything you need to
know please go on
we begin by filming benji from the waist
up
on a green screen and composite that
onto a shot
of the ground for the ground effects
basic after effects 3d layers glitches
mosaics
find edges but for the face it all
begins with face gen
face gen is a horrible horrible piece of
software it does
everything wrong but it gets you one
thing right and that's it gets you a
face
and will give you a 3d model in which
you can use so i just manually animated
the face for the entire shot
the key element was just a simple manual
animation of the eyes to look down and
around
in panic in a moment of realization of
the horrible fate before perishing into
the ground
yeah man we got it we got it we got it i
wish you the best
you want to take a step just for old
time's sake no i've stayed away from
this for a very long time
i've had far too much i think i'll
probably vomit if i taste it
[Music]
[Applause]
so we have successfully gathered the
footage now i just have to figure out
which take they used for the actual
effect so the way i'm going to do that
is i'm going to bring in the
glitch final export that's up on youtube
and i'm going to bring in the original
footage and i'm going to line them up
to see which take exactly they used for
the final effect
now that we have our footage all set up
it is time to start doing some 3d work
but how are we going to do
3d work on 2d footage well i'm going to
convert
that 2d footage into a 3d model with an
algorithm
that can look at a 2d photo of a human
and turn that into a 3d model it's
developed by some people over at usc
and facebook so let's give that a shot
see what happens
so i tried running the algorithm
and i got a pretty scary result didn't
quite work
my guess is that the algorithm got
confused because it didn't have legs and
i only fed at the top half of mario and
i maybe it doesn't understand it's like
where's this guy's legs so i actually
dug through the original footage and i
found an outtake where benji was just
chilling and so i grabbed that still and
i fed it to the algorithm
and it worked so i figured since we're
taking a bit of a modern approach
to this 10 year old effect might as well
use some modern equipment so i got my
rococo motion capture suit on and i'm
gonna capture some motion let's do it
help me
uh
we got our motion capture data that's
the best we're gonna get and so i'm
gonna bring that into blender and start
playing with it let's see what happens
so i went ahead and i brought the 3d
model into the scene and i set up a
rough
3d version of the original set and i
have to say
this 30 90 and this computer is like
it's like a bear and my render is like a
salmon
and this bear is just ripping that
salmon apart in seconds
what i'm trying to say is that the
geforce rtx 3090
is a big ferocious gpu with titan class
performance
one of the biggest limitations of doing
3d work is not being able to see what
your scene is going to look like until
you spend
hours rendering this time adds up and
you end up wasting precious work hours
just waiting
on your old tin can to show you
something useful but with the 3090
inside this machine i honestly
completely forgot that this was a
problem for real though i really don't
ever have to switch out of rendered view
i can pretty much
just set up my scene while seeing pretty
much the final render
inside the software just makes the
workflow in general a lot easier so as
i've been working with this beautiful
computer i've honestly been a little bit
concerned because it goes so
fast and renders things almost
instantaneously
and that made me worry that there was
some kind of dark magic going on
so i did some digging and it turns out
that this computer is actually powered
by ampere which is nvidia's 2nd gen rtx
architecture and it's doing that with
new ray tracing cores tensor cores and
streaming multiprocessors
and let me let you in on a little i
didn't have to clear my cache once
during this project it has a staggering
24 gigabytes of g6x memory which
delivers i have to say the ultimate
experience
they've also managed to accelerate video
encoding and decoding
so playing 8k footage back no problem
and nvidia graphics cards also run off
of nvidia studio ready drivers which
means that out of the box
it's going to be stable it's going to be
optimized for creative tools and it's
going to be fast
as freaking heck i have to say those
people over at puget were like
i know what you need and they crafted
the perfect system for corridor fits our
needs perfectly check out the link in
the description to see how you can get
your fingies on a
geforce freaking rtx 3090 powered system
from puget systems link in the
description
right there to digitally recreate the
environment i took a still photo of the
background that they got on set 10 years
ago and i projected that onto some
geometry once i had that information i
could go ahead and put my ground plane
in
and then extrude up bits like the wall
the dumpster
and then i added in some little plants
and stuff and it ended up looking pretty
damn good
as far as animation after bringing the
motion capture in the first thing i'm
doing is i'm going through
and i'm applying scaling effects to the
whole animation little
things where the arm will like bulge out
and then bulge back and the head will
shrink and then bulge up really big and
that's kind of the first passive
animation i'm taking
after this i'm going to go and add the
eyes which i found online
by wild artworks on blend swap and so
i'm throwing that in
animating out of mario's head the final
shot ended up being about 30 seconds
long which is more than
700 frames that this system had to
render obviously the computer absolutely
crushed it
and in a couple of hours i had a high
quality render ready to nestle its way
into a youtube classic
the last thing i'm going to add is a
vocal performance to really sell
the pain that mario is going through
help me
no of course i thought this was gonna
like take five hours or whatever to
complete and
ended up taking way longer as usual
that's always the case that's always the
case always
always but i'm really happy with how it
came out and i'm excited to
show it to the guys sam is a very busy
man and you are pulling away from a very
important meeting right now
show him this shot that's honestly a lot
of pressure and i don't know if i'm
ready for it but uh
i hope i did it justice that's all i'm
hoping for all right george lucas
we'll see about that you like my dead
rat at the end of my rc car
i honestly don't think you could ever
live up to the original but my hope is
that it respects the original and builds
upon it to prove
how much better i am at vfx than sam
ever was
look here's the thing look we got
ourselves a remastering situation here
you know look at star wars
they remastered that and look how many
people complained
do you remember how much george
lucas got after he decided to
change up the vfx in his movies well
miso want to sniff a yagunga
peter you're in dangerous territory here
i was about two years old when that
happened so i don't have a firm memory
of it but uh
i remember star wars being pretty good
so yeah peter when you were
negative 30 star wars was much better
you know i'm just hoping that the
original audience the
the the ogs if you will will not uh you
know skewer me
for ruining this timeless shot it is
just the thumbnail
the thumbnail that won 20 million views
youtube broke with that thumbnail over
christmas
and that's how we got 15 million views
so was that the expectation for this
video yep all right
here we go y'all oh
you gotta reset the game i got you man
hold up
um
ah
oh my god oh my god that is so much
more than i was expecting yeah same what
they had bad layers dude i thought it
was over it kept
going i got tears i have tears peter's
tears of joy
that was so beautiful that's the past my
every expectation
we gotta watch that again
okay
[Applause]
you turned that one one second shot into
a full video i'm happy with how it came
out
i love the spotlight the sudden
spotlight is the best
yeah oh stop it stop it not behind the
back
how fast did that stuff render though
because that was like a high quality
render for a very long it took
honestly like three hours it was not bad
nice yeah well the 30 90 it was
crazy i could literally watch it in
rendered view as i watch the animation
oh my god it was nuts
yeah wow jeez i can't wait to work with
more 30 90s
that's so cool so these crazy
experiments would not be possible
without the support of you guys
particularly our patrons
i want to give a couple thanks to a
couple special people first off
appropriately
thank you glitchcube for helping us on
patreon and thank you not a canadian spy
alan almanza phillip oxford and harris
reds and pagic
jordan sunil s daniel webster
phillip when jack beck thank you so much
if you'd like to check out our patreon
the link is in the description thanks
again for watching see you next time